To solve this the first thing I want to know is how many moons can fit into the earth's shadow?
How many moons widths are there associated with this time spent in eclipse.
Well, 205 minutes is 3.42 hours.
Now, I have this conversion factor here,
which relates hours to moon widths, so why don't I use that?
3.42 hours times--well, now I want to invert this, because I want the hours to cancel out.
This guys has got to go downstairs.
Times 1 moon width per 0.93 hours.  Hours cancels. Sorry. This should have been a 2.
This equals 3.68 moon widths.
Since we said the shadow was the same size as the earth,
this is equal to one earth width.
Let's divide this by 3.68, because I want to know what 1 moon width is.
I find it's one earth width divided by 3.68.
The moon is 3.68 times smaller than the earth.
I don't actually want width. I want circumference.
Let's go over here and say the moon's circumference, MC,
is equal to, well, 1 earth's circumference divided by 3.68.
That's going to be 40,000 km--that's the earth's circumference--
divided by 3.68, and the circumference of the moon is about 10,900 km.
Great work. This is really amazing.
You've calculated the circumference of the earth and the circumference of the moon.